have you ever heard of prince charles
being referred to as the duke of
cornwall or read the poetry by lord
byron
or simply watched an episode of downton
abbey
following the exploits of the family of
the earl of grantham
well you may have wondered where these
terms come from
and what they mean these titles duke
lord earl are all related to nobility
the nobility was and is a social class
with its origins in feudal europe during
the middle ages
feudalism was a social and political
system in which a king of a country
bequeathed land and political privileges
to nobles in exchange for services to
the crown
which usually meant fighting in war as
time turned to the late medieval and
early modern periods
this system became more hierarchical and
more convoluted arriving at the somewhat
confusing system we have today
in this video i will be disentangling
some of these complexities as i
explain the ranks of nobility
the rings of nobility changed from place
to place
and change through time some systems
were very complex
like in the holy roman empire whose
dizzying geographical and political
complexity
was mirrored in the structure of its
nobility and some systems were more
simple
like in the empire of france where
napoleon simplified the
previously complex system of the old
regime
we will be using the british system
because it's the best known
and is still in use to this day there
are
five ranks in the british system in
order of presidents they
are duke marquess earl
vi count and baron each with their own
female equivalents in anglo-saxon
england
before the norman conquest in 1066
there was but one rank in the nobility
the earl
the term earl has two possible origins
either coming from the old norse ural
meaning leader
or elder men from the anglo-saxon which
meant basically the same thing the
female equivalent
countess gives a hint to what the rank
was called
in continental europe count
yes like that guy the earl was the basic
noble lord in feudal england
controlling the different counties yes
that's where that name comes from
of the land earls are to be referred to
as
lord so and so and countesses as
ladies so and so after the norman
conquest
william the conqueror introduced the
baron
in normandy the term baron meant much
the same
as earl a representative of the king in
different areas of the country
in this case called a barony but during
the melding of anglo-saxon and norman
societies
both terms were used and eventually
baron became the rank of nobility below
that of earl
barons and earls who themselves were
automatically
given the title of baron were often
called to the king's council
this tradition eventually evolved into
the house of lords
the female equivalent to a baron is a
baroness and while you may hear
barons referred to as baron so-and-so
the correct form of a dress
is like with earl's lord and lady
in the year 1337 the title of duke was
introduced to england
when king edward iii gave his son the
title of duke of cornwall
after losing his own title of duke of
normandy
the term goes back to the roman empire
and was used in the german and french
lands after the fall of rome
originally the title of duke was only
held by royals but was later expanded
it is the highest rank of nobility and
the title is only held by 24 people
today
in britain they traditionally ruled over
duchies
the female equivalent is duchess and
dukes and duchesses
are to be referred to as your grace
these three ranks duke earl and barren
are the building blocks of the system
and subsequent ranks are derivatives of
these ones
a marquis is the second highest rank
above earl but below duke
the term comes from the germanic march
meaning borderland
so a marquis translates to oral or count
of a march
the word margrave was used in the
germanic lands
before it came to england being
introduced by richard ii
in 1385 whose brother-in-law was the mar
grave of brandenburg the title marquis
was actually quite unpopular in the time
after it was introduced many earls were
insulted that the rank was placed above
their own
the reason giving for its higher ranking
was because amarquis's territory was on
the border
and therefore strategically more
important than a normal county
the female equivalent is martian s they
are referred to as lord and lady
and in some circumstances as the most
honorable so-and-so
lastly we have the vi count as the term
implies
the name comes from vice count like vice
president
and the post originated as the office of
the deputy to account
or the sheriff of a county but later it
became a hereditary
rank in the holy roman empire in the
12th century
it first came to england in 1440 and was
placed above the rank of baron
the female equivalent is vi countess
they are referred to as
lord and lady so those are the five
ranks of the british nobility
again they differ from other historical
structures of nobility elsewhere in
europe and when you study those systems
some
questions may arise like why our princes
sometimes placed below
dukes and why are some countries not
ruled by a king
but a prince or an archduke and wait
what is an archduke anyway
and what's a baronet well those sorts of
questions will have to wait for another
day
thanks for watching okay a baronet is
like a hereditary knighthood
sort of it's in the british system but
it's not considered noble
whatever anyway thanks for watching my
video on nobility
subscribe if you haven't already like
the video if you liked it comment
letting me know what you think
check out some of my other videos if you
want to learn more bye